- I have one job.
Making the best clothing in the world.
(upbeat music)
My name is Martin Greenfield.
I used to be Maxmilian
Grunfeld when I was born.
But I changed it to make it American.
Because I love this country.
My craft is very difficult to define
because it's many things.
I am a maker of clothing.
I know how to measure.
I know how to fit people.
Very few people could match me.
I was responsible for all the Presidents.
Clinton, I measured in the White House.
Obama, measured in the White House.
So then I made them perfect suits.
We never had to fix nothing.
(loudspeaker)
My life was a sad life
before I came to America
because I lost my family.
I was left alone, everybody was dead.
We were occupied,
Auschwitz was a month later.
I was in the concentration
camp a year and two months.
It was my second day in Auschwitz,
there was no more names
at the concentration camp,
only numbers.
When they called me,
they sent me to a tailor.
The head tailor spoke my language,
he was Jewish.
They asked me, "Are you a tailor?"
No.
I said if you could show
me how to make the collar.
He says, "I'll make you a collar."
Showed me how to make a collar.
The pain is still in my
heart about my family.
I still dream about my
family like they're alive.
But on the outside you will never know.
I didn't think I was gonna survive.
I was liberated by Eisenhower.
General Eisenhower came in
when I was 15 1/2 years old
and when they walked in,
I shook his hand crying,
"You saved my life".
I came to America, September 18th, 1947.
They gave me the job as a tailor.
I told my boss,
"Listen, Eisenhower liberated me.
"I want you to make him a three-piece suit
"like I wear myself."
He like it.
Once he had the first three-piece suit
from then on you didn't see Eisenhower
in nothing but three-piece suits.
So that's how it started.
I made sure we dressed all the Presidents.
With Obama, first he
wanted me to copy a suit.
I don't copy anybody.
Everybody copies my suits.
So, if he wants me to make something
I have to measure.
Next day, he sends an e-mail
"It will be a pleasure to meet you there."
I'm happy when I'm at the factory.
My job is the most
important thing in my life.
Quality is so important to me
because I know that's
what kept me in business
and that's why I'm here talking to you.
(upbeat music)